videos recorded by u.s navy personnel
have added a new layer of evidence to
the current national debate about ufos
for the first time radar images recorded
inside a navy ship
have confirmed the presence of several
unknown objects
that swarmed around the ship for hours
i-team reporter george knapp here with a
story that broke today on mystery wire
thanks brian over the past three years
or so the public has been able to see
several astounding images
of what certainly qualify as ufos during
encounters with the u.s
navy there's no question that the
pentagon has sensor data to go along
with the photos and videos
but none of that information has been
leaked or otherwise released
that is until today
for two long hours on the night of july
15 2019 the crew of the uss
omaha detected on multiple sensor
systems
unknown objects that surrounded the ship
as it moved through
ocean waters west of san diego one of
the objects
a self-illuminated sphere at least six
feet in diameter
flew alongside the omaha for an extended
period
and was observed through a thermal
sensor in the ship's combat center
filmmaker jeremy corbell released the
navy video weeks ago
and says similar events were reported by
eight other
navy ships in the same area over three
days
mark varying range there was numerous
warships that are having
similar um appearing it appears to be
coordinated
interaction and uh and this and this
whole
series was within this kind of i'd say
circumference of a hundred miles and and
there was up to 50 to 100
contacts in the last three years the
pentagon has reluctantly confirmed the
legitimacy of ufo
images captured by navy ships and air
crews
including these photos taken off the
coast of virginia
and the better known videos the
so-called tic tac incident
and the gimbal but other than the images
themselves there's been no release of
sensor data
to buttress these cases there is now
obviously a general that long where
we're at
in that the number of contacts you got
to force the speed leaders off them
over a period of hours crew members on
the uss omaha which is located in the
center of this radar screen
monitored the approach of the unknown
objects as many as 14
at one point all around the ship two
different radar systems watched the
objects
and estimated their speed track 781 just
fed up to
46 knots 50
[Music]
the images from sources he declines to
identify the pentagon's uap
task force considers the omaha spheres
to be true
unknowns the ships that were under
observation by the unknowns
were unable to track where they came
from or where they disappeared to
the omaha sphere appears to have
vanished into the ocean
at that point it also vanished from all
sensors
in one video snippet nine of the objects
were seen
around the omaha but two of them dropped
off somehow
invisible to two radar systems and it
supports the hypothesis
that these are not just a balloon
dropping into the water or it's not
um something that is easily explained
these are true
unidentifieds in mass number and we'll
talk more about that but that's what
we're showing people
where you have radar data that goes with
fleer data
what everybody has been bellyaching for
so here you go
if these are foreign-made high-tech
drones how do they fly with no wings
rotors or detectable exhaust do they
possess some sort of cloaking ability
the sensor data combined with the video
images raises difficult questions
these are unidentified we don't know
what they are
everybody tries to corner me in saying
they're aliens or somebody i have
no idea george knapp 8 news now
the video of the radar screens consists
of four clips that were spliced together
to show that this went on over a period
of time
today less than four hours after that
video was made public by us
a pentagon spokesperson confirmed it is
legit that it was recorded by navy
personnel
and is in the hands of the uap task
force that's the unit created to prepare
a report for
congress that is due next month